ああああああ
par
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
はい熊野ご自身で私の人生ははりました
ん
ボウガンたい一般社団 og わぁの人では
夢精10億南氏は中学日カード18日ちゃうの
終わり町にある音符も被害がひどかったロシア師の方に入りましたん
その時
シェーブしそして炊き出しという形を地域の人たちと活動してきました
もう忘れられていることかもしれませんけども
お湯は決して忘れてはいけないことだと思っております
今からを
することはその熊本地震の時に
活動正規化お話ですので皆さんしっかりいっ
静かに聴いてください
お話したいところですけどすごいに行ってるんですねー
8ちょうどですねぇーか被災地に入ったときにもこれぐらいの子供たちがで聖竜あい
ました
8そうだねええええとも退屈なムービーだねええ東毛
生存へ上がってくるかで定格1 day その遊んでみましょう
じゃあへと会社には友達上に上がっておいでどうぞ
はいは結構たくさん言うんですね子供たちがれてこの会場裏はですね
ハーイはいいねぇねぇ集まれ集まれ
はーい
ではーちょっとね色々昆布薄くとか持っちゃっていいですね応援すごい登場の仕方だな
ハーイさぁみんな
さあじゃあいいですかアロマないるじゃ上に上がっておいでー
はーいじゃあちょっとその風生し他の人にあげとこかねはーいじゃあそれではちょっと
皆さん集まれ集まれ気を付けぴ
わーかっこいいねぇ先をつけ p できるかなー
さあじゃあね先生ねみんなた
のが初めてだから先生のちょっと自己紹介をしたいと思います生成は
遠い遠いアヒルのクリからやって来ましたドナルド先生と言います今日はみんな
よろしくお願いします
はいよろしくお願いしますじゃあねちょっと先生の音ま猫してもらおうと思うんだけど
ま猫できるかなちょっと座りましょう
はいじゃあねそしたらみんなはこれできるこの動き
初期
初期日 p
これねお腹に力がないとね後ろにころりんていっちゃうんだよ
できるはいいね
はいじゃあちょっとバイ姿勢を正してさあちゃれい先生より早く立ってくれるいい
いくよーメディ号
もう早いなぁじゃあね今からドナルド先生と一緒に皆体を元気いっぱいもりもり動かし
てもらおうと思うから
広がってください
はいどうぞ
さあ広がって広がってそれではねぇ
今から音楽が流れるからみんな一緒に踊ってくれるかな
じゃあそれではね行くよああ行くよいいねぎー
torano デー
ano ano デー
t you do
re too
ana
焼いたよあぁん
to you
yeah
ヒューて釣りは誰
ana
私が悪い
佐々
[音楽]
ゆっくり急所
よいしょよいしょいよいじゃんえっ
いよい暑いーよいしょ
さーて次はどんな生き物なろう
お城しじゃおう
ko ang
ano ang
ハァハァピーター次はいいいいいい
ana 位
お尻上げていっ
今日はいいいい
ええええええ
[音楽]
ana よきよぴよああ王アーサーデー
pwh
がんばっ日
pa や次はどんな市場論2
[音楽]
nan
me
後ろ a
美味しいよっていいいいいいいい
あーじゃあ次はコレとコレなんだ
[音楽]
bl
eroanime nao
yeah
[音楽]
じゃ米 b な集まり集まれさぁみんな楽しかった糸てあげて
楽しかったねー先生も楽しかったじゃあせっかくだから会場の人たちもさぁみんなの
ことで拍手してくれたから
せっかく高い照明とまぁそんぢゃうかじゃあ今ミーナ飛行機持ってるで
じゃああー下にいる彼以上の人に飛行機をえーいて投げるんだけど
会場の人たちも土橋返してあげてください飛行機キャッチ行ってみよう生の a
さあ会場の最もだけってあげて a
わあああタホはわーいー
4以上
よいしょ
a
大ちゃ雛楽しめてるねさあじゃあ今からそこまでで終わり
ジョヴィのもう一回圧針圧マネー
ああああああああ
でっいまっててねそうじゃあいいですか
上記をつけぴは誰がかっこいいかなーみーてよはいじゃあいいですか
常念とっても楽しかった人てあげてはーい
いいですかジャガーんみんなは今度から生成また続きのお話をしたいなぁと思うんだ
けど
またゆっくりさん皆さん静かにお話聞けるかな
はみんな静かに消えるから
ありがとうじゃあねみんなまたお家の人とゆっくりお話聞いててねはーい
yeah
とっておにぎあいましたさあ
じゃあね早速ちょっと続きを話そうと思うんですけど
すいませんあのお時間になったみたいなのでこれでちょっと自分のお話ししたかったん
ですけどこれで終わりたいと思います一般社団法人ワードピットのお方となると先生
でしたありがとうございました
二位